eigentlich ist es ja jedem klar in
unserem Gesundheitswesen stimmt
irgendetwas nicht wir haben zwar eines
der besten der Welt sagt man allerdings
auch ein sehr teures wir geben etwa eine
Milliarde aus nicht im Jahr nicht in der
Woche jeden Tag ich war deutlich mehr
als ein Milliarde die Zahl der
100-jährigen steigt ständig wir werden
also sehr alt aber es sind zwei
verschiedene Dinge alt werden oder
gesund alt werden wenn man sich das mal
anschaut dann hat ein deutscher
65-jähriger gerade noch einmal
sechseinhalb Jahre gesunde Jahre vor
sich auf die er sich freuen kann ein
Norweger dagegen die Skandinavier machen
das irgendwie besser der hat noch ganze
elfeinhalb gesunde Jahre Vorsicht was
machen wir obwohl wir sehr viel mehr
sogar für die Prävention ausgeben also
die Vorbeugung als die Norweger irgendwo
kann der was nicht stimmen wir sind
Weltmeister in den Arztbesuchen wir
rennen hin das ist in unseren allen
Köpfen drin wenn du krank bist dann geh
zum Arzt wir haben unser Leben
medikalisiert wir haben überall Medizin
und wir verlangen immer mehr Medizin wir
verlangen vom selben immer noch mehr
mehr Ärzte mehr Krankenhäuser mehr Geld
für das System ich glaube wir geben
unser Geld für das falsche aus übrigens
Geld was wir so wie es alle aktuell
gerade diskutiert haben zunehmend
überhaupt nicht mehr haben und wir
brauchen und das sage ich nicht mehr
Ärzte obwohl da immer unisonopolitiker
Krankenkassen Ärzte alle ein Meinungen
sind auch Patienten dass das so wäre ich
glaube wir brauchen nicht mehr Ärzte es
ist Zeit umzukehren wir müssen wieder
mehr auf uns Menschen auf unsere
Eigenverantwortung pochen die Leute mit
einbinden und selber feststellen lassen
wann gehe ich zum Arzt wann muss ich
wirklich hin wann ist es richtig wie den
Fortschritt richtig einbinden ich bin
froh über jedes neu erfundene Medikament
aber ich glaube nicht dass wir jede
Operationstechnik zum Beispiel in jedem
Alter tatsächlich anwenden sollen ist
dann kein Segen für die Menschheit Herr
Stock was tun sie denn für ihre
Prävention ich mache hier morgen
Liegestütze
und ansonsten
mache ich nichts aber ich lebe
eigentlich danach dass ich so lange das
mache wie es mir noch gut geht aber ist
die schaden sich wahrscheinlich auch
nicht es rauchensee okay
[Gelächter]
aber glauben Sie denn dass die Deutschen
zu viel zum Arzt gehen gibt es da ich
glaube das ist eine eine große
Verunsicherung gibt ja das glaube ich
das ist durch
größere Angebote auch möglich ist nicht
Sicherheit zu schaffen sondern
Verunsicherung zu schaffen da gebe ich
Ihnen recht es gibt immer diese schöne
Beispiel aus den
schlechteren Ländern Afrikas wenn sie
dann Waisenhaus hinbauen dann gibt es
mit einmal ganz viele Weise die ist
vorher gar nicht gegeben hat also wenn
Sie Ihren Krankenhaus hinbauen und viele
Ärztinnen werden sie auch wahrscheinlich
mehr Patienten finden das ist sicherlich
richtig ich glaube aber auch für dieses
Angebot wenn es nachgefragt ist auch
irgendwie schaffen sollten ich habe sie
hier mit einem Appell verstanden auf
sich selber zu hören und weniger zum
Arzt zu gehen das finde ich es völlig
richtig und was wollen Sie denn machen
wenn die Menschen anders ticken das ist
es das ist ein ein eine Veränderung die
wir auf allen Seiten brauchen ich sage
nicht die Patienten drin sind dran
schuld oder die erste sind dran schuld
wir alle in den letzten 40 Jahren haben
uns dahin erzogen auch die Kassen haben
damit gemacht die Politiker haben auch
mitgemacht immer mehr Medizin wir haben
die Eigenverantwortung hinten angestellt
weil wir eben so viel machen können das
ist ja ganz toll haben wir aber es auch
in jeder Variante eingefordert zum
Beispiel nehmen wir mal die
Darmkrebsvorsorge die kann ja Leben
retten oder ich muss ehrlich sagen
während der corona-zeit hatte ich das
Gefühl es gibt gar keinen Krebs mehr und
heute würde ich sagen wenn jemand in
seinem Umfeld oder so ein Mann über 50
hat oder eine Frau sollte er dringend
sagen
ein super Beispiel genau das ist es die
beste Vorsorgeuntersuchung die wir haben
warum weil ihnen einer einzigen
Untersuchung kann man den das dass das
Ding was stört direkt sehen und sogar
noch wegnehmen das ist genial beim
Prostatakarzinom viel schwieriger da
gibt es eigentlich keine gute
Vorsorgeuntersuchung Mama also eine
Mammographie schwierig das muss
beurteilt werden dann gibt es auch
falsch positives alles alles viel
schwieriger Darmkrebs das ist so etwas
da würde man sagen unbedingt wer 50 ist
als Mann oder 55 als Frau unbedingt da
mal hin mal reinschauen lassen das ist
ein sehr schönes Schlusswort für heute